[Musique]
le premier épisode hier de la caméra
cachée de greg ou vraiment il pousse
benjamin castaldi à bout regardez la
deuxième partie elle est folle c'est
parti bonjour j
le vois bien heureusement
ou c'est juste que je voulais en venir
au fait tu t'es casser un peu la figure
et que je me dis qu'à l'époque il y
avait les lofteurs et tous et que moi je
t'admire et les lofteurs hills ont
disparu en un claquement de doigts ils
sont tombés dans le gouffre et comme
s'il avait amené l'animateur avec eux
quoi qu'ils me parlent de restaurer sa
facture s'est déjà fait ça fait quinze
ans que chez red bull en carton position
télé ça je faisais en carton et philippe
baumel problème d'intérêt jusqu'à ce que
tu connaissais pas ce que j'ai fait
quand je dis juste que j'ai fait
rapidement les nouvelles parce que tout
est ok j'étais en recherche sur des
chroniques humoristiques sur a2 cela
bien maintenant c'était en 2013 je
supporte explosé sur effectivement à mes
jeux non non je suis pas un transit qui
sait demain par un poids et moi en verre
en terrasse qui pense que c'est tout ce
mois qui vont prendre en photo et c'est
toi qui tiendra l'appareil du fair use
elfique best just le couple une cohésion
à temps c'est beaucoup et en dehors ton
nom les gens reconnaissent c'est à dire
quand il voit ta tête ils savent encore
quitté c'est que y'a moneo toi tu es à
l'étagé un peu moins deux au moins chaud
au 5e et que justement et j'ai juste une
envie j'ai envie de tendre le bras et
d'appuyer son numéro 5 et que tu me
rejoignent avec moi et qu'on se passe au
sommet et que là on croque ensemble et
que la hausse intel ont évoqué castard
gastal moi je vois qui sait je pose
seins qu'elle commence h qui est qu'à
spa l'idée c'est déjà qu'il traite à
chaîne youtube quel registre pour les
vidéos on a remarqué qu'un beaucoup
d'émissions de cocher aujourd'hui en
télévision qui marche fort toi tu as un
beau corps et donc tu peux le toit dans
drôles du coach qui avance est assez
crédible et on s'est dit là que le
guennic ce serait casta ça castagne
je m'explique test-achats testing as tu
as un casting comme un jingle qu'on a
préparé on va le montrer après dans des
sacs des serres castet sa castration des
cas ça castagne casta ça castagne
il s'imprègne le voisinage par l'ong
t'arrive tu sonnes le mec il ouvre et
direct ufmd est le cas ça castagne
c'est peut-être
j'étais peut-être pas très bien et du
coup on s'est demandé ce qui pourrait
justifier le casting est un truc autour
aidera cette heure de jeu est naturelle
mais prennent le voisinage mais qui va
confondre cet appel doit repasser pas du
tout mon registre là parce que je suis
par hacker que j'ai le casting tout le
temps non mais elle casta qui marche en
gros ça veut pas du bricolage parce que
ce fait casta ça bricole ou casta ça
déménage parce que si vous des mails
alors ça marche parfois c'est juste mon
parti ok j'ai l'impression qu'on prend
quoi ça ce que je fais avec
je vais hériter pas du tout bon et est
habile total c'est un charlot mer les
charges ont écrasé par des peuples
jamais est vraiment cet homme parce
qu'ils passent chez moi je me suis pas
barré des temps depuis quelques jours le
cubain parce que caster c'est le casting
je fais bien fait gaffe avec 70 pape sud
on peut voir que je te casse la traite
on a tout à fait beaucoup d'entretien
cauterets allait aller et que les gens
pensent que trois fois sur quatre il
reprend double attentat trouve quoi bien
tout à l'heure on était à deux doigts
c'est parti pour que le caleçon chili
mange tout aurait sauté à la gorge
c'est à vous dégoûter le haut en fin de
semaine sur les gens mais là ce sera toi
du coup ça casse
si je peux terminer juste et ferme
abandonnée
parfois quand benji tient de ce qu'on
vient voir et 4 sata pour la proposition
d'eric l'internet comme ça prétend que
devra contrer notamment dans la lah
[Applaudissements]